there's an energy about this conference
that I have never seen in any other type
of scientific conference the people who
are here are so excited to learn and so
excited to also share their knowledge
with everybody else
science food camp is not a traditional
scientific conference in fact this kind
of formats known as an unconference
and it was inspired by conferences that
had already been going on in the
technology sphere run by Tim O'Reilly
and his colleagues hi I'm Tim O'Reilly
I'm the founder and CEO of O'Reilly
Media and I'm the O'Reilly in friends of
O'Reilly which was the name behind foo
camp we had moved into a new building in
2001 we had a lot of empty space and we
thought let's throw a kind of a party we
can camp out for all of our friends we
did it
the first time just for a lark it was it
was for fun but then it turned out to be
such a powerful idea and we learned so
much from it essentially the idea is
that we invite two or three hundred
interesting people from a variety of
fields that means from across different
scientific fields but it also means from
the sort of as it were the periphery of
science so writers philosophers
businesspeople with with an interest in
science and we let them really determine
what the what the subjects of discussion
are going to be Google hosts science who
camp very simply because we think that
cross-discipline work in science is both
difficult and something we should
encourage there's a lot to be gained by
scientists of different stripes and
different fields talking to each other
and it's actually very rare in the world
for people to do that
meeting so many people who are so
passionate about whatever field that
they're in and hearing them share that
passion and their excitement enthusiasm
what they're working on and then seeing
the connections because it's all related
to things that other people are working
on but seem completely unrelated and to
see them realize we're actually solving
different aspects of the exact same
problem and we never would have known it
hi my name is Andy Hicks and I'm from
Jackson University Department of
Mathematics I'm a mathematician who does
mostly applied things and I came to
cypher to show some of the mirrors that
I've designed which include a driver
side mirror without a blind spot and
this mirror which is a non reversing
mirror and if you look up I've got some
text here that says Sai foo but if you
look at it reflected in this mirror you
can still read it as if it's regular
text my technique for designing mirrors
is very general in a way you ask a
question like how do I want to see a
portion of the room that requirement
translates into some mathematical
equations I take those equations have a
lot of computer software written over
the years then the computer will spit
out the shape for me and I can see a
picture of it one thing I love about Sai
foo was the informality mathematics is
very formal the traditions go back
hundreds of years and a lot of the ways
people behave are very much the same
cipher is completely well it's an
unconference it's unstructured
so science bootcamp doesn't have any
predefined program we start off on the
first evening with a blank schedule
board and we ask the attendees
themselves to fill it in for us and so
when you have 200 people standing up at
once going towards the board saying oh
I'd love to talk about XY or Z or I'd
love to to get this person to give a
talk about that it has this sort of
glorious chaos the real secret of it is
to invite interesting thoughtful people
I mean come on if you had a bunch of
really smart people over to your house
would you think you had to have a
program in fact we've invited in a
couple hundred of the smartest people on
the planet of course they're gonna find
things to talk about and it works every
time
my name is Matt Cowell and a year ago a
friend and I started DIY by that org
which is a community for amateur
scientists online and essentially it's a
bunch of people interested in doing
non-institutional science so taking the
notion that you don't have to go to get
a PhD for six years to figure out how to
do science you really can do it with
duct tape saran wrap sugar well I
decided to run a session on programming
bacteria with biological parts because I
have some friends who've developed what
they call standardized biological parts
the bio brick standard and it's really
neat it's a synthetic biology idea they
basically put the DNA actually I printed
this so I put the DNA of the on/off
switch and the gene for making the
banana odor in e.coli on this car that's
right here it's this coloured part plus
documentation about how the part works
and to me it's really interesting
because you can imagine this plus some
cells that are really ready to execute
the DNA which we had in this case
donated by a local scientist those two
things combined maybe you could have a
deck of these and you you would
basically be able to give that to
someone and they could experiment with
all sorts of little biological Legos
make new combinations and really get a
sense for how easy biological
engineering can be or at least
biological plain you can just sweep your
arms like that and actually this is some
bacteria with the that biological part
put inside of them and they're slowly
growing in this liquid right now this
broth so what we just did outside was
take the card cut the little piece off
of DNA from the paper drop the paper
into some cells that were ready to
absorb the DNA and then we put
essentially the cells into broth so they
could grow and multiply and tomorrow
hopefully this will smell like banana
the core of the bootcamp idea as its
evolved is really about cross
fertilization between disciplines I was
part of a session and there was a group
of us who were talking about online
communities and the potential of
children or volunteers worldwide
actually browsing through
high-resolution images to actually help
us find real fossils in the field at
Lake Turkana and the potential now is
there if we can secure the online the
high-resolution imagery there have been
a number of very interesting people here
that I've been able to talk to
particularly from the Google imagery
Google Earth Google Mars group who have
a good handle on high-resolution imagery
and how to actually bring that across to
the public and I think now we're
probably at the beginning of trying to
make this happen the collaboration that
has led us to scishow is a great example
also of the kind of thing we're trying
to accomplish think about it for a
moment we have three different
organizations very different businesses
Google the search engine O'Reilly a
computer book publisher and conference
producer and Nature Publishing Group a
scientific journal coming together to
create this cross-disciplinary event and
what's so important there is that for
none of us is it directly connected with
our explicit business what we're all
interested in doing as organizations is
creating value for the world and for our
community
so my name is pawel Curtis I'm a
computer scientist software engineer
Software Architect at Microsoft I also
run a very small online store for
mechanical puzzles I was commissioned by
the organizers of sigh whew oh nine
to create a custom puzzle just for size
ooh I think some people are actually
trying to solve it so I'm hoping more
people try to solve it so now this
puzzle I wanted to design a puzzle it
had an answer not just a solution as to
say I wanted there to be some one-word
answer that you somehow got out of
solving it but that's not what normally
happens with mechanical puzzles so the
idea with this puzzle was not only do
you have to put all the pieces in the
tray it tells you at the bottom put all
the pieces in the tray and that's one
thing and it fills up the tray but
there's several ways to do that and most
of them aren't satisfying because these
little bars that are on the pieces don't
line up with anything and it turns out
if you do find the way to put them in
with all the bars that lining up what
you'll discover is that's made another
puzzle and now you have to solve that
puzzle and it turns out that when you've
solved that puzzle there's a third
puzzle and after you've solved that one
there's a fourth puzzle and that one
gives you the final answer and that's
that notion of a multi-stage solving
experience was something I really wanted
to play with and the puzzle that I
designed for Sai foo is in fact the
latest in my series of multistage
solving experiences so it's another four
stage puzzle so for the people that Sai
foo keep working you'll know when you
finished
my name is joyridin Burke I'm a
comparative anatomist I teach anatomy at
the Mount Sinai School of Medicine and I
do my research and looking at animals
adapted to extreme environments and this
is my second cypher conference one of
the great things about science boot camp
is the bones so I brought with me a
crocodile skull this is actually one
from Australia and this skull it's
beautiful it's got all these really cool
teeth in here but what I really like
about the skull is the nostrils on the
top here so if you look and you can see
these little nostrils right here and
what's amazing about this animal is that
it can grab its prey and start to drown
its prey by bringing it under the water
but still be able to breathe because the
nose is all the way out here is a tip
and so it can actually be pulling
something under the water and still
breathe on its own
there's a lot of talking and then
there's a lot of eating and there's a
lot of talking and like eating and then
suddenly it's over talking to people
their brains haven't yet processed what
has happened this weekend and so this
comic is sort of my improvised attempt
to capture that feeling so if I had to
sum up the essence of cypher I think
it's all about the people and I think
what I would say is great people make a
great event there's a veritable fountain
of great ideas coming out of everybody
and this is just like conversational
paradise Tim O'Reilly likes to say we're
bridging new connections in the global
brain or something and it really feels
like there's a seizure going on or
something that's great
we're altima looking to make connections
between people who don't know each other
but who should and that's why we don't
invite back the same people every year
we're always looking to make new
connections
you